dr payne will be giving brief updates
and answering your questions here in
just a minute
as you're all aware across the country
and here in the national capital region
we've seen a general uptick in covet 19
positive cases
as we head into the holiday season we
wanted to take this opportunity to
re-emphasize the importance of taking
preventative measures to mitigate
against the spread of coronavirus
particularly following cdc guidelines
including wearing a mask social
distancing
hand washing staying home when feeling
sick and other efforts
from the start the department is allowed
in covet 19 mitigation and response and
we are determined to do so in the coming
weeks
as announced on thursday the pentagon
reservation will transition to
health condition bravo plus tom will
talk a little bit more about that in a
second
we have seen dod facilities around the
country adjusting
their health condition levels in the
last few weeks depending on
local conditions just last week the
acting sector was in norfolk when the
facility increased their condition
level to charlie and we expect to see
other increases
in the coming weeks these changes are
based on authorities delegated in march
giving commanders the flexibility to
respond in the best interest of their
personnel while maintaining
mission effectiveness we will of course
keep everyone
posted on additional forced condition
level changes
as you're aware and as many of us just
heard a couple hours ago in the press
conference by
operation warp speed we've seen
tremendous progress on what is now the
third vaccine candidate
that is shown to have strong efficacy
rates against covet 19
and we are all tracking that the medical
experts at this fda
will consider emergency use
authorization of vaccines in the near
future
thanks to the vital efforts by the
administration's operation warp speed
under general purna
and our partners in the private sector
we are now a significant step closer to
ending
the covet 19 pandemic and in the coming
weeks
americans will begin to see vaccine
distribution far and wide
the department continues to support this
whole of government response and is
immensely proud of the work that has
gone into warp speed
up until now we have a long way to go
but the department's prepared to assist
in any way necessary
at this point i'm going to turn over to
to uh mr rapawano
uh for some opening comments thanks john
the department of defense has three main
objectives
for kobe 19 response the first is
protection of the dod workforce and
their families
the second is safeguarding the
department's mission capabilities and
readiness
and the third is the support to the
whole of government and international
responses for covet 19.
dod's primary support to u.s government
response has been providing military
medical personnel to augment civilian
medical facilities
in areas experiencing high covet
hospitalization rates
today there are over 20 thousand
national guardsmen deployed in 52 states
and territories
providing coveted support dod has
military medical personnel
on prepare to deploy orders available to
support state and local requests for
assistance that come through
fema and hhs within as early as
48 hours upon request our current
support includes
62 medical personnel that's three
medical support teams
to support three hospitals in el paso
texas
sixty nurses and additional personnel to
support local hospitals
and long-term term care facilities in
north dakota
and in guam we have 18 medical
professionals for 24
7 telemedicine support for the civilian
hospital
on the island we also have a small
critical care physician
team being sent to a local hospital in
guam
we've had significant transfer of
personal protection
equipment since the spring of 2020
dod transferred 20 million n95 masks
approximately over 7 million covet test
swabs
and almost a thousand ventilators to
federal departments and agencies for
coveted support
on the research and development front
the department has spent
almost 1.5 billion for covid19
research and development in fy 20. so it
really is a whole of government response
and it's a whole of dod response in
terms of being ready
to support other federal departments and
agencies in their support
to civil authorities around the country
as we see
cases come up
thank you jonathan i'm tom you're a
director of washington headquarter
services as mr hoffman mentioned
as a result of uh following on with what
ken just mentioned
where workplace safety for our people
and their families as their number one
priority we've adjusted the force health
protection condition or hp con here in
the pentagon
and we moved from bravo to bravo plus
which essentially tightens
some restrictions we're publishing that
guidance is already out on www.wgs.mill
as well as defense.gov website for the
latest guidance we also are updating
our employee handbooks which are
available all of our pentagon entrances
let me kind of recap the changes that
we've made to our health protection
condition guidance here in the pentagon
once again we believe that these
measures are an abundance of caution
and prudent when you look at the actions
taken by the governor of maryland
virginia the mayor of dc over the last
several days to mitigate the spread of
covid in our communities
our measures are in strict alignment
with guidance from center for disease
control
under bravo plus we are not reverting
we're not changing our phased opening
status
we still remain at phase two of our
pentagon plan for resilience
so we're not closing more portions of
the pentagon we are however
particularly due to the holiday season
adjusting our workforce in the building
moving from a goal of 80 of the building
20
telework moving to a goal now of 40
percent in the building 60
telework we've been achieving about a 50
50
mix really since about the last several
months with about 50
of the workforce in the building of
course this aligns with the holiday
period
where a lot of our workforce are taking
advantages of time with family and
friends in terms of leave
but they're also taking advantage of the
ability to continue the mission
through a distributed and virtual
workforce environment we're also going
to maximize
as we mentioned telework not just for
our normal employees but of course
continue to ensure
that those that are vulnerable to the
most serious consequences from kovid
remain at home and do not come into the
office we are also of course mandating
cloth face coverings remain
a requirement on the pentagon
reservation if you cannot maintain
social distance
we're going to increase the random
frequency of our checks at the main
entrances to the pentagon we currently
are doing about five percent we're going
to move that to about 10 to 15 percent
once again these are checks for health
and readiness or health and wellness
rather of individuals coming through the
pentagon if they've been exposed to some
with cove 19 if someone their family has
been diagnosed with covenant 19
or how they feel this morning do they
feel ill sick fever and then a
cross-check of temperatures
and then of course if they are found to
have been exposed and or have a
temperature were referred to their
supervisor
and then refer them to proper medical
authority so they can receive the
medical care that they need
gathering on the pentagon reservation
will be reduced from 50 as our maximum
down to 25
once again in order to help us maintain
salsa distance through the holidays
we of course continue to have increased
parking available in the pentagon itself
because many of our mass transit
partners are not necessarily at full
operating capacity right now
so whenever employees are choosing to
drive to the pentagon in single
occupancy vehicles
the food court will move to take out
only we'll restrict kind of access to
food courts
some of our vendors of course will scale
down some of their hours but we
anticipate their continued support
as we go through the holiday season to
hbcon bravo plus
and i'll turn it over now to dr lee
payne and i'll take questions later
thank you
well good afternoon thank you all for
joining us here today both in the room
and those on the phone
i'm the lead for the coronavirus task
force
diagnostic and testing line of effort
i'd like to take this opportunity to
bring you up to date on some key issues
concerning
cover 19 testing within the department
in partnership with the services and the
combatant commands the defense health
agency
and the joint staff as the lead for
diagnostics and testing
my mission is to standardize and
synchronize coven 19 testing
across the department in order to
mitigate risk
to the force in alignment with the
department's priorities we're also
tasked to
determine the best location for
equipment material and supplies
necessary to perform
coven 19 testing and direct their
transfer movement or delivery
as necessary based on the service
validated operational requirements
since i last provided the update on this
topic in july
we've continued to execute tests above
the department's
original estimates of fifty to sixty
thousand tests per week
we're now conducting over seventy
thousand tests each weeks and ha
and have been for the past five weeks uh
these numbers are inclusive of active
duty duty service members
and select reserve and guard uh units
such as
deploying reserve component units we
also continue to perform diagnostic and
screening
testing on family members and retiree
beneficiaries
and to date we've conducted over 1.7
million
tests since january now the ability to
perform over 70 000 tests in a week is
not a singular effort by the department
uh we could not perform at this level
without the help of our
inter-department interagency and
industry partners to procure supplies
and integrate and implement emerging
technologies department testing capacity
has continued to expand greatly since
the july update
at that time there were 125 department
labs certified for covid 19 testing
around the globe
with the capability to conduct about
over 200 000 tests
as of last week we have 158 operational
laboratories
with the overall capacity to conduct
nearly 300 000 tests per week
though the department faces supply
challenges that are in line with the
rest of the country
we've continued to find creative and
agile solutions to mitigate any
shortfalls
these solutions include the use of pool
testing
leveraging existing partnerships with
commercial laboratories
and implementing new testing
technologies and despite these supply
sorted intermittent supply shortages
the department is regularly able to
complete over 99 per
cent of the required tests each week
since april
uh when we started the landscape as a
cova test force line of effort
the landscape for the covet testing 19
testing has continually evolved and our
strategy has as well
originally the department's strategy was
heavily reliant on molecular cova 19
tests
for the detection of sars kobe 2 as
those tests are
the gold standard for detection they
often become
supply constrained during demand spikes
to mitigate this
we've worked to expand our testing
toolkit to include new technology
such as point of care molecular test
oral swab and antigen tests
and additionally we've leveraged cdc and
fda guidance
to develop protocols that help front
line clinicians
determine the right test for the right
situation depending on the patient's
unique circumstances
we've also taken key steps to identify
critical points in this
testing supply chain and appropriate
actions to mitigate those
shortages throughout each phase of the
pandemic we will continue to lead from
the front
identifying and investing in new
technologies that will allow the
department
to accomplish accomplish our mission and
protect our force and families
the department continues to emphasize uh
foundational public health measures that
remain essential to stopping the spread
of cove at 19.
like much of the rest of the nation we
are seeing increased positive rates
across our system as we work to identify
those
that may have the disease and are at
risk for transmitting it to others
i'm proud of the work completed to date
but we know there is much
yet to be done the combined efforts of
the department's testing strategy
and enforcement of required public
health mitigation measures
has enabled the department to
effectively manage the challenges of
covet 19
while most importantly continuing to
meet our operational requirements
we look forward to continuing to expand
our partnerships capitalize on and
implement new emerging
research technologies and capabilities
that will allow us to grow our testing
ability and further reduce the spread of
covert 19.
ensuring mission readiness and keeping
our service members and their families
safe
i wish you all a safe and happy
thanksgiving week
and as a physician i offer my thanks my
respect
and admiration to those colleagues on
the front lines caring for patients
across the military health system
and the nation this week i look forward
to answering your questions
okay with that we will open it up to
questions i'll go first to
the phones for ap is bob on the line
uh yes yes i am yes i am thank you
jonathan
uh can i ask jonathan a couple quick
questions
um first uh you mentioned operation
warp speed can you
tell me what is the military's role if
it does have one
with regard to providing security either
physical security or cyber security for
the vaccine production and distribution
uh my second question is about whether
you can bring us up to date on the
transition interactions that have
taken place so far between dod and the
biden game
okay i'll take the first one and i'll
have tom talk on the
on the second one because uh uh in
addition to being responsible for the
pentagon reservation here he's also the
director of the uh
transition task force so um on the first
question
warp speed briefed earlier today general
perna gave a pretty lengthy description
of what's taking place i'm not going to
get into the the security protocols that
they have put in place
uh that's that would not be appropriate
of me it's going to be a combination of
a number of different teams
it is something that they are taking
into consideration that these are
valuable vaccines and we need to ensure
that they get to
those who are most in need of them first
and so there are security
provisions in place but i would refer
you over to warp speed for that i don't
want to speak
behalf on behalf of them and what all
measures they may be taking in addition
to dod's
support so i'll turn over to tom to talk
on the
transition well thank you jonathan
jonathan mentioned i'm the head of the
department of defense's transition task
force
as such i'm accountable to carry out the
requirements of the statute of the
presidential transition act of 1963 as
updated eight times since then
and we have a dod policy that guides our
actions during transition activities and
of course we've got governance boards
that meet with the deputy secretary
and key leaders here in the department
that's provided monthly status updates
on this process
since early june last evening we did
receive a
a notice last evening from the gsa
administrator
in response to the presidential
transition act of 1963
that made certain post-election
resources available to the biden harris
transitioning team
the head of the biden harris transition
team did reach out to me personally last
night we had a conversation
via email and we had our first meeting
this morning
between the department of defense and
the biden harris transition team what
they call the agency
review team or the art the art you'll
hear that referred to often
this is a line both once again with the
presidential transition act
the white house and biden harris
memorandum of understanding
between those two organizations and dod
policy
we are aligned with our statutory
requirements we are executing our
responsibilities under the presidential
transition act and our dod policy
we're looking forward to continuing the
process with the biden harris transition
team in the near future
and throughout the transition period all
right
bob we'll go next uh is phil are you on
the line
uh we'll come back in here in the room i
had a question for ken
regarding the deployment regarding the
deployment in north dakota
i think you said it was to lawn care
term assistance
what impact has the covid spike in north
north dakota particularly around minot
had on on defensive positions the
norad sites and other defensive
activities
that are part of the department of
defense has that influenced the
deployment
is that did you guys initiate the
deployment or was that request of
fema hhs please thank you so this came
through the esf8 the emergency support
function
council of fema hhs and dod participates
in that group as well
ultimately the group considers the
prioritization considers the
actual need or degree of need by the
requesting state or locality
and then they make a recommendation fema
provided
us with a confirmed request for
assistance for that support
so that support was not predicated on
dod personnel at any of the facilities
in
in the region does it have an impact at
all the covenant in north dakota on the
dod facilities in the state
so i don't have a base by base uh
takeoff but but we do see a relationship
between the caseload
and localities in the vicinity of dod
facilities
but of course our demographics are
different than the general public so we
don't have
uh we haven't experienced the yet of
hospitalizations that we've seen yeah
sorry you did say long-term care
assistance correct in north dakota
yes to long-term care facilities correct
thank you
okay all right could you explain
why there seem to be so fewer
deployments now of military medical
teams than there were last spring when
the
uh the first spike occurred and now
we're in a much bigger wave
but the deployment seem to be a lot less
why is that
so the real reason is number one the
diluted
case dispersion around the country
you're not seeing that
heavy heavy load that we saw in the
northeast northern new jersey
and new york city where it overwhelmed
the the medical support
systems in place they have essentially
developed enhanced treatment
capabilities that reduce the amount of
time spent
hospitalized for individuals so across
the board there are a number of
improvements based on experience dealing
with the cases
also based on the dilution of the cases
per geographic areas where we're not
seeing the degree el paso we've seen
significant case loads where in some
cases the hospitals
were becoming quite quite full in terms
of their bed space
and that's where we focused our support
but as you noted significantly less
to date that could change when and if
that changes we want to make sure that
we have
sufficient capabilities to address those
circumstances that
are are the most needing how many
personnel do you have on these
prepare to deploy orders so we have
hundreds now and we can increase
as as needed okay
we'll go back to the phones uh we'll go
to a carlab
hey jonathan thank you so much for doing
this um this question is for you since
it's the first
opportunity to ask a question to you or
the secretary since
the announcement about uh drawing down
forces in iraq and afghanistan further
i was wondering since violence in
afghanistan is up 50
for the last quarter to this quarter
that's according to cigar
and commanders have repeatedly told voa
and others that the taliban haven't
shown conclusively that they're going to
break with al qaeda
what are the conditions that are driving
this decision that on the ground
and then also secondly when the
announcement was made a senior defense
official had told reporters
on background that the cuts were going
to result no elimination of capabilities
on the ground but
several u.s military officials have told
voa
that a significant reduction of forces
like this would lead to at least some
reduction of the scope of the mission
if all the missions indeed were going to
continue in afghanistan so can you
help square how we're going to lose
nearly half of the troops in afghanistan
and nearly 20
of the troops in iraq and none of the
capabilities are going to be lost
so ultimately the department of defense
is implementing the commander-in-chief's
decision
with regard to these these engagements
and so as we saw the the president had
received advice from his national
security team he received advice from
his military commanders
and then he made a decision on what the
force levels would be within afghanistan
and iraq
i was not part of the briefings with the
president um so i i can't share the the
conversations that took part in those
decisions those conversations
uh but the overarching conditions and
these were discussed last week
and i know all of you are aware of it as
uh would a reduction in forces result in
a national security threat to the
american homeland
our people in our interest and would
would our forces still be able to
continue the operations necessary
to maintain a posture capable of
mitigating any such future threat
that may emerge and the the decisions
with those was that
the reduction was not going to uh to put
our national security at risk and that
with the force level that the president
has directed that we would be able to
maintain the ability to respond in the
future
uh so so that was the the calculus uh
that's my understanding that
uh was based on the president's decision
uh that he gave
um i i can't speak to your your second
question as to
what some of your your sources may have
said i can uh
be happy to put you in touch with uh
with the uh centcom and
and uh resolute support leadership uh to
get their actual take on it
uh but i can't speak to the the the
unnamed sources you've mentioned there
all right we'll go also the phone tony
capaccio
hi sir i have a couple questions one
was the this was the move to bravo plus
it all precipitated by an increase in
the positivity rates
of of covet testing of personnel on the
in the pentagon reservation
and i have a second question i'll take a
first crack at that in the turnover time
uh the decision to go to bravo plus was
made um
a a few days ago i think late last week
um i know there's some uh
speculation and questions where were
posited to us
about uh the uh the visit of the latvian
uh defense minister lithuanian defense
minister
um and whether that had any impact the
decision to
increase as tom mentioned before is a
reflection of the local community all of
our bases are part of local communities
and so when we look at what the force
protection level is it is a reflection
of what is happening
not only within our facilities but
outside of those gates
as tom has mentioned our our personnel
more so at our bases in the field than
at the pentagon are much younger
healthier dynamic than
than the surrounding populations and so
we have a little bit of a different
calculus
but that is what we look at we look at
what's going on outside the gates and
we've seen both the governors of
virginia and governor of maryland and
the mayor of the district of columbia
all
increase uh their their measures to
counter
covet and so we respond to that as well
i don't tom if there's anything else
i just say that aligned with our local
communities know we are a product of our
communities that we live in although the
pentagon is significantly lower
covered spread than any other building
that i'm aware of in the d.c
metropolitan region
because we have a well-informed
well-educated deliberate workforce that
takes care of themselves and their
families
wears protective masks washes their
hands and maintains social distance
whenever possible to do their mission
we are seeing of course much like the
rest of the nation
the impacts of social gatherings
particularly when we let our guard down
and do not use social distancing or
masks to protect ourselves and our
families
so we did see a positive bump around the
community here in the dc maryland
virginia areas
due to social gatherings bars
restaurants etc which of course
the governors and the mayors have
commented on we saw the same here in the
pentagon workforce
sylvie um i have a question about the
transition
so stay tuned
[Music]
i wanted to have a little bit more
details on
how it works because i don't know how it
works
so is it daily meetings
that you are going to have with the
transition team are you going to give
them some
[Music]
intelligence about what's going on how
how is it going to work sure once again
our reference on this is the
presidential transition act of 1963
which has been
updated eight times in statute since
that's kind of our baseline and from
there
gsa in partnership with the white house
has developed a very rigorous and
well-defined
best practices playbook in fact it's
actually published there's a playbook
for a presidential transition that's
actually published
by our friends the partnership for
public service and other non-profit
agencies
that kind of capture these best
practices over successive
presidential transitions throughout the
years part of our
responsibilities under the act is to be
prepared to receive the agency review
teams
and then provide them updates on the
department of defense activities
in preparation for a presidential
transition
that process actually began many months
ago where we had to deliberately
by statute once again provide what we
call a plum book which is a listing of
all
non-career political appointee positions
in the department
a succession plan that says if there's a
vacancy in the department
that there is reliable uh continuity of
leadership within the department of
defense
for each of our missionaries and for
each of our organizations
and finally we had to provide what we
call interim transition books
which essentially are a primer if you
will of organizational structures
budget mission charters
all the details that go into running the
organization which includes the military
departments
the joint staff national guard bureau
and of course our office of secretary of
defense components
it's a very detailed elaborate
deliberate system
it begins with engagement follow
ascertainment by the gsa administrator
which was effective last evening
therefore we've had two discussions now
with the agency review team
those will be daily discussions moving
forward likely
and will be responsive to the
requirements while ensuring that we
implement the national defense strategy
united states during this time of
vulnerability for our nation
all right we'll keep going on the phone
uh aaron defense news
yeah thanks jonathan um two questions
first i'd like to get an answer to
tony's question about
when the secretary as well as the other
service secretaries who had interactions
with the lithuanian minister
were last tested if they tested negative
and then more broadly just
what's the the plan for exactly where
service members and families fall in the
priory list for
receiving the vaccine going forward sir
i apologize tony i i forgot to respond
to
your question i i must have blacked out
there for a minute
um i uh as we talk as of the statement
we provided last week when we were first
made aware of the lithuanian minister
that we conducted testing of of
the senior leaders that had contact with
the minister
uh and then people with our practice
i'll let you know if there's a positive
test
i'll tell you that at this time we
conducted uh
testing and the only positive test that
came out of the the testing with regard
to meetings with the lithuanian minister
was the previously reported test
positive test of tony tata
so with the the the second question was
with the guidance so
with vaccines this was kind of discussed
a little bit on the the warp speed
call this morning with secretary azar
and and others
within the department of defense we
historically follow the advisory
committee on immunization practices cdc
and fda guidance
and so they're meeting they're having
conversations about what the final
guidance would be i can give you
generally what the initial
um guidance for cdc uh vaccinations is
and that was going to be
and this is from uh from that
organization this is uh that
we would be uh likely following was
healthcare personnel non-healthcare
central workers
adults with high risk of medical
conditions
and adults with high risk mental
conditions and people
65 years of age or older living in
long-term care facilities
you'll see from that list that the
department
may not have a huge number of
individuals
that fall into those initial categories
most of our personnel
particularly uniform personnel are are
much younger
uh under the age of 30. they're they're
fit
not a lot of secondary high-risk medical
conditions
and so we'll be looking over that in the
coming weeks
as the plan is put together uh we've
been in
contact with uh cdc and and the uh
in putting our plan in place and
reviewing it i know that there have been
meetings undergoing at the department
that the
uh this the deputy secretary of defense
is leading this review
as we establish this plan under the
direction of uh the
defense health agency um and as soon as
we are at a place where we're prepared
uh with the approval of cdc and and
fda to release that information we'll be
doing so and so
that's a briefing we plan to provide in
the coming weeks
your medical personnel would would
get the vaccinations along with their
compadres in the civilian world
just from the guidance i can't speak to
our inter internal guidance because it's
not finalized and i haven't reviewed it
specifically but i'll give you the
guidance that is provided from
uh from cdc and from the advisory
committee on immunization practices
which the initial guidance they gave was
to
was to uh uh in part prioritize
healthcare professionals
so barbara mr could i take you back to
the issue of tran
of the transition planning you're doing
and the way ahead
because my question is sort of the same
as sylvie's for those of us who aren't
terribly familiar with the regulations
and the policies
i think what we're maybe looking for
some very practical ways to explain it
so um when you say for example when you
say daily meetings
because there's so much teleworking can
you tell us will the transition team
have
full office space will they be limited
on how many people they bring in do you
think
your meetings and hats was your meeting
virtual will many of them be virtual
kind of just looking for a lay of the
land
and more specifically um
i didn't hear you mention that you
mentioned the kinds of things
they would be briefed on as part of the
regular
uh way of doing this does that include
do they get military intelligence
briefings
do they have access to military
personnel
and that what what level perhaps
the big question
are you the decision maker do you get to
decide what is done or do you
have to run everything through chief of
staff patel
for his permission and the secretary's
permission so we'll let tom take the
first seven of those
i'll take the last one um but but i
but i don't want to i don't want to
devolve this in briefing into just a
transition briefing because we do want
to hit the covid related issues that are
facing us uh
uh as we approach thanksgiving so i was
raising my hand consistently so i
think mr muir probably doesn't find the
answer at all
and i said we'll be happy to take the
first time we'll be happy to take the
first seven of those so
um some begin with the meetings um
age review team obviously reached out
last evening we had our first
discussions
and exchanged electronic emails first
meeting today was by
video teleconference virtual a good
productive meeting as we kind of laid
out sort of the ground rules
i can tell you that the team is uh
willing and certainly
able to abide by the coveted
restrictions here in the pentagon they
agree
with the protection measures that we're
doing for our families our
employees ourselves our colleagues our
comrades here in the pentagon they're
looking forward to
participating in discussions in the
pentagon in fact i'm
providing a small tour on monday next
week for some of the agency review team
leaders here in the pentagon there is
dedicated office space
for them in the pentagon and the
reservation here in the building
actually
that we provided for them it allows for
social distancing
for six feet between workspaces to
include video teleconference capacities
at the
unclassified side and at the classified
side
as you discussed there will be many that
want updated intelligence briefings and
updated briefings on operational plans
many of those once again by statute one
of the many changes over the last
50 years 57 years of the presidential
transition act is to allow
the department of justice and the
federal bureau of investigation to
initiate background investigations and
security clearances
on many of the agency review team
leaders so many will come here with
top secret clearances adjudicated
investigated adjudicated by the
department of justice reciprocated by
the department of defense
which will allow them access to
intelligence they'll have access
at the appropriate levels would sign
non-disclosure agreements because once
again the materials that they're going
to review
once again particularly if they're
classified many are not for public
distribution or release
they'll be privy to and will respond to
their queries
their questions their requests for
deeper dives briefing materials
products releases in terms of the
decision processes
we work in support of the secretary of
defense for this operation
it is part of our alignment for
professional efficient effective and
transparent
where the agency review team process and
we're committed to doing that while
executing our national defense strategy
so
we have prepared for this for quite some
time for six months
uh we are prepared to receive the agency
review team i believe that some will
work in the building i think some will
do virtual
some of the members are not in the dc
area we think we'll be communicating
with them via video teleconferencers
either at the secure side
or the unclassified site if that's the
dialogue that they want to get into
and we're committed to both supporting
our statutory requirements
and to continue in our mission here in
the department all right all right
uh we'll go to um scott from fed news
network
i thought he handled the my outstanding
question is
what is the level of approval from mr
mirror
and what does everything have to get the
chief of staff patel's approval
the secretary's approval at what level
do
decisions to share information or work
with the transition team
have to be approved by the chief of
staff or the secretary and
i thought tom answered it there at the
end there on saying that the goal here
is to be
professional efficient and transparent
and ensure that the team has the
information that they need to
be successful and ensure that our
national security through this
throughout this transition time
is insured there will be
uh decisions are going to be made on uh
regard i think there's some
classification
conversations that that'll go into it
and i think uh
part of it taken to count is the
secretary's in charge of the transition
i mean the the
acting secretary of defense is in charge
of this transition tom is
is the going to be the career uh
official handling he's been working very
closely with the deputy secretary on
this
i think tommy said the deputy secretary
has been uh ensuring that the workspace
is
is correct and that the the binders have
been reviewed uh is making sure that
that all has been done
uh appropriately um i spoke with uh with
the chief of staff today um and he is uh
he has assured me that
uh tom euros is the lead on this and
that he's going to be uh
working with tom and tom is going to be
the one working with the uh
the team today the chief of staff
reached out to the agency review team
lee today as well
to provide his contact information let
her know that if they if she needs
anything
that she is welcome to reach out to him
uh his goal is to be
uh the touch point for the secretary and
ensure the secretary
has insight into what's going on and to
make sure that the transition is
successful
okay if i could just end in two quick
thoughts of context one is that we've
been running a governance process in
support of this aligned with our policy
for quite some time as i mentioned
there's a senior steering group that
meets monthly in fact we're probably
going to increase that now that there's
been an ascertainment
led by the deputy secretary and the vice
chairman so senior leadership in the
department participates i provide them
updates every month about our current
status of preparation our plans
next steps and the next meeting
structures we're also meeting what with
what we call the transition assistance
coordinators
these are designated senior officials
general officers and career senior
executives
in each of our cabinet agencies each of
our military departments joint staff
national guard bureau
our office of secretary defense
components we meet weekly
just met monday and we discuss and again
to include i'm sorry the combatant
commands as well have a representative
on this transition assistance
coordinator process
we meet with them weekly and we update
them as to the status of
both our plans activities next steps
there's where we're going to have the
real discussion on deliverables
materials
next set up of meetings scheduling
senior leaders for interviews with the
agency review team
we work these through our partners so
it's a collaborative governance
structure
underneath our policy structure all
right let's go back to the phones uh
scott
from uh fed news network yeah good
afternoon
um so you know the past few days past
week or so we've seen
really some of the largest numbers and
spikes for service members being
diagnosed with covet 19.
i'm curious i realize that this is up to
local commanders but do you expect
i think you have about 60 percent that
are open or don't have restrictions
right now do you expect that number
to go down as these cases continue to
rise
and is the defense department as a whole
considering any other sort of policies
that might go in effect
now that you have uh nearly 75 000
service members who have been diagnosed
uh to date scott with the 60 number what
what exactly are you referencing with
that
uh that would be the number of bases
that are military installations that
have uh eased their restrictions and
gone green
i'm not sure that that number is exactly
right i i and if it
if it was correct at some point in the
the recent past
i would expect that that number you're
going to see an increase of facilities
going to
um charlie i think the navy has across
the board has uh has increased their
level to charlie
uh we've seen facilities uh i think
i mentioned norfolk in the last week um
facilities in in the northeast so i
think you'll you'll
continue to see that once again that's
going to be
decisions based on local communities and
in the operational needs of the services
and the bases so i think yes we will see
those those
those closures go up back to the
question on generally
will there be any additional dod
measures put in place
we feel comfortable with the levels that
we've put in place
in the past and that we have we have
weathered this relatively well
based on the guidance that was provided
back in in february of this year
uh as as ken pointed out the the
number line the number one priorities of
the department were to
protect our people and ensure we
continue to do our missions and so those
guidance
that has been pushed out by uh former
secretary esper
and the continuation through acting
secretary miller
has allowed the commanders to make
decisions they need to protect their
forces
so i don't see any any blanket changes
in policy that are
that are being considered uh i think
we'll continue to watch and let
commanders make the decisions on the
ground
um and uh and then we'll do things like
we're doing here today is to
to reiterate to our forces and to double
down and let them know that take these
measures seriously
there's nothing wrong with commanders
and and everyone stepping up to
restate the the need to wear masks to do
social distancing to wash hands
and and to follow through with those uh
mitigation measures
um and and then at the the second part
we're gonna look to support the
the operation warp speed and vaccination
efforts uh and hope to reach a point in
the near future
where vaccinations are are out the door
and and people are being treated and we
start to see
a a different curve with respect to
dekovet
all right we'll go to uh nick from pbs
all right not hearing nick we'll go to
jeff from task and purpose
oh thank you two quick questions will
families
and service members be required to get a
covered vaccine
and has defense secretary miller
responded to bill belichick's request
that the us control
turkey and azerbaijan over the war with
armenia
um well fortunately i will say that uh
that there is a peace uh
agreement in place uh right now in in uh
uh between azerbaijan and armenia that
uh appears to
be holding at the the current point so
we may be able to forestall having a
summit between the acting secretary and
coach belichick to discuss that
and then with regard to
your first question which i forgot
already
please remind me jeff sure will
troops and families be required to get a
culver vaccine will it be mandatory
uh i don't have information for you to
share on that right now
um i'm gonna defer that answering that
question to when we give the vaccination
update in the uh
in the coming weeks and we'll have a
fuller
uh conversation about what will and will
not be required but
at this time jeff i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna be able to share that
all right uh we got a couple more megan
oh
jeff took my question okay the bill
check question yes
okay all right now no
i do have a question this was a little
bit murky in in
your response to tony and aaron but when
was acting secretary miller's last
negative covet test
so i we've we've kind of set the
standard before that we're not going to
get into every single negative test that
a senior leader does um i can just say
that in the time the secretary has been
here whether it's between
testing prior to travel testing as a
result of
the close contact that was reported
testing due to a white house meeting
he's been tested more than a half dozen
times in the two weeks that he's been
the secretary of defense
and i have no positive cases no positive
test results to report
um all right we'll go to the phones for
the last one uh courtney cooby
my question was asked as well thanks all
right
you follow pretty all right
yes yes porn i would like to ask um um
the doctor something so can you
for for people who work in this building
in the pentagon the issue of contact
tracing
is confusing to me including reporters
who work here
and i was wondering if you or whoever
the appropriate person is i apologize if
i'm asking
this question um well my question is is
really this
so somebody is tested and they come back
positive and you might say to them so
who have you
who have you been in contact with in the
building in terms of contact tracing
inside the pentagon
well most reporters never hear of
any cases of positive because we're not
told of positive cases in this building
how can you advise the news media to
ensure that they have full awareness
of who may be tested who may be positive
so we're not inadvertently
being unknown spreaders asymptomatic
anything like that nobody's ever really
explained it to us and
this is the opportunity for us to ask
what
how do we learn more about what's going
on inside the pentagon
sure from a from a pentagon perspective
we do have a very robust contact tracing
program but you're right though it
relies upon
reporting gaddafi reporting that if i am
sick
and i tell my supervisor that i was
tested in my local community
and that i'm positive for kovit then my
supervisor would report that
into our operations center here in the
pentagon which rolls that up to joint
staff
from there within 24 hours we're our
policy right now is to
contact the person who is reported to be
positive
and then ask them who they've been in
close personal contact with particularly
during the time period that they were
symptomatic
and you're right there are many people
that are asymptomatic they're tested and
they come positive
and so we look for 48 to 72 hours prior
to their
and oftentimes it's a little bit of lag
in terms of testing right you get tested
you find the results two or three days
later hence the cdc guidelines asked for
48 hours before they were symptomatic
shows an opportunity to spread the covet
virus inside the workplace
so then we ask them who has been in
close personal contact for
more than 15 minutes now it's over 24
hour period
less than six feet without a mask on or
with a mask on
and we identify those people by name
what helps is when they maintain
where they understand who they've been
in close personal contact with and
oftentimes in a building this size with
nearly 11 000 in the workplace most days
it's hard to remember who you've been in
close contact with and so we asked them
to give us the names of those they're in
close contact with
and then within 48 hours we're
contacting those personnel
and asking them if they're feeling
symptomatic
are they feeling sick do they have a
fever have they
anybody in their family feeling sick
have a fever showing symptoms then we
ask them to
notify their local physician and get
tested here in the building about
a third of our workforce or military
about a third of our workforce
are civilian and about a third of our
workforce are contractors
and so it's kind of a mixed um
demographic if you will for healthcare
provision
and so we're relying a lot on local
healthcare authorities
and then all the numbers that are
positive on the pentagon reservation
report up through public health
authorities so arlington county
alexandria county fairfax county pg
county montgomery county
they're aware of any outbreaks in here
we do not
by policy and by process notify folks
hey there's somebody in this cubicle
that was positive however if you're
notified by a
contract tracer that says you may have
been in contact with
a certain person that was in the
building next to you more than 15
minutes in a meeting with you
we'll advise that person to get tested
right now the cdc guidelines does not
require testing for asymptomatic but
i'll ask dr payne to kind of
uh no you did a great job almost an
honorary medical
degree there tom but uh you know no we
we would not necessarily
test everybody who has a contact
for example secretary miller comes in
contact with a
lithuanian minister who later tests
positive
secretary miller tests negative you have
no reason to inform to
to tell people including reporters that
may have been near secretary miller
that they need to be tested i would say
you know a test is a test only
at that point in time and that's why we
also recommend
quarantine or isolation for those those
contacts because the disease could
develop over time nobody ever tells you
they're in contact with a reporter
because i think i think what barbara's
talking about is is um
there's a chain i think tom hit on it
there is it's it's contact
close contact is the cdc requirement and
then there's contact
and then there's contact with someone
who had contact and so the question
you're asking is
um why doesn't somebody tell you if
you've been in contact with somebody who
had a close contact
and i think that's not the guidance
that's not the cdc guidance that the
the risk in that chain until someone is
symptomatic or has tested positive
that that chain is not there um and i
would just say
the other thing is is tom mentioned the
process we have in place the
the uh the i apologize the bureaucratic
process we have in place for for
notifying
but i think what you'll see and and
people see in the building and um
is thursday the just general uh
relationships that people in the
building of somebody test positive of
reaching out to their co-workers and
letting them know
reaching out to people that they have
been close contact with immediately to
let them know i've seen that in cases
recently where
an individual may have tested positive
and and they make it very clear because
people want to know quickly
because the best way to stop the spread
is to very quickly
notify people that's why we say if you
have symptoms don't come into work
go get uh go see your doctor or your
health care provider
the sooner the better so that we can
stop the spread and so that
we see that a lot happen in the building
because we have a responsible workforce
that understands the implications of
having a number of tests here
so i'm just going to close up with a
couple of final remarks and then we'll
let you guys uh
out of this room so i just want to show
you as i mentioned we'll be back with
some additional briefings on transition
on vaccinations in the coming weeks as
more information becomes available and
so i'm sure tom will be with us for that
and we'll have the appropriate people
from dha to come in and talk about the
vaccination plan
so we've seen a lot of stories about the
fact that uh with the
thanksgiving people aren't able to
travel people aren't able to be with
families and just a note of perspective
for for viewers and readers
that and for those who are discouraged
by not being able to travel this holiday
due to
coven 19 and just ask you to remember
that there are millions of military
members who over the last two decades
have missed many holidays in the service
of the country deployed across
across the globe in defense of the
nation this is not an ideal situation
but we're optimistic that with the
progress of warp speed the light is at
the end of the tunnel
in closing i want to reiterate why we're
here and that's to talk about
talk to our dod personnel and our
service members at home and abroad and
encourage them to follow the cdc
covet 19 mitigation guidelines over
these holidays
take proper precautions regard to
necessary quarantines wash your hands
regularly maintain social distancing
limit the size of gatherings wear a mask
and
if necessary choose not to travel
and also please make sure you observe
local regulations uh finally
i just want everybody to remember that
social distancing and hand washing are
excellent excuses to get out of
uncomfortable family conversations about
politics at thanksgiving
so just recommend everybody abuse those
excuses often
throughout the throughout the holiday
season and hope everybody has a good
thanksgiving
thank you
you